I am Aimee Beger from Y Combinator and I
have the distinct pleasure of
introducing Emily Weiss here thank you
so much for joining us thank you for
having me so did you see everybody
so Emily you founded two brands that
have a pretty beautiful symbiotic
relationship your first was into the
glass which began as a beauty focused
blog in 2010 as a side project when you
were a fashion assistant at Vogue and
you later use the audience of the
audience and the content that you built
there to launch glossier in 2014 and
glossier is a direct-to-consumer beauty
brand with a stunning line of products
which basically power the external
appearance of all women who work at Y
Combinator so thank you so much for
making us all feel beautiful every
single day so you've said that both into
the gloss and glossy a focus on beauty
as an element of personal style and
celebrate women sharing their own makeup
reviews product recommendations and
beauty routines of with one another and
into the gloss now attracts nearly 1.5
million unique visitors every month so
something that you're doing is really
resonating with women how did you first
identify the women needed a platform to
have these kinds of conversations yes
it's a good question
so the one common thread that still
motivates all of us at glossier today
and were you know 95 people in Soho in
New York
we're actually 77 percent women we have
over 40% female tech team and also just
before I divert it into it I walked in
here when you guys were all like lining
up around the front and first it was
actually unfortunately probably all the
women in San Francisco I feel like we're
are all in this audience like god forbid
something happens like we're all human
race is going to like but no it's really
cool I mean I go to a lot of these
things as I'm sure many of you do and to
see like this just the whole thing
flipped and ever the energy in here is
so awesome so it's great great to be
here but the conversation around beauty
it's a really interesting time to be in
not just in startups and and in
technology but in beauty and view
something that you know when we were
pitching when I was pitching by myself
you know our seed round like back in
2013 beauty was not you know this like
hot thing that it is right now like I
had meetings just like a couple of
venture capitalists yesterday and like
and it's it's it's a good time to be in
beauty but I think the reason why is
because Beauty is this great conduits
you asked like how did I recognize that
there should be this platform beauties
is great kind of like activator for
women to connect with each other and
share with each other and to really
develop and hone a voice and and that
might sound silly but everybody has
something to share about beauty right
like I remember this woman Jean Godfrey
June she was a beauty editor at Waukee
Magazine for a really long time and when
I interviewed her she was like beauty's
just like great connect equalizer like
among women you can be you know like
meeting someone for the first time
really nervous but if you're like I love
your lip gloss like what color is that
like you know you're like oh I love this
lip gloss I was like ten of them been
wearing it for ten years
so everyone has something to say so I
think it's a really cool time to be in
Beauty because technology is just
completely upended the traditional you
know paradigm of like brand to customer
kind of like these you know mega brands
who have this perfect look and this
whole range of products you have to sit
down and encounter and they do your
whole face and then they make you guilt
trip you into buying all the products
and they expect that those are the only
products you'll ever have in your
bathroom really you've got like you know
an assortment and so I think it's really
cool that right now you should be
encouraged to be your own curator of
your own life in every arena you know
whether that's you know what food you're
eating or what blender you're buying
like I always use the blender analogy
that if you're going to buy like a
Vitamix on Amazon I'm never going to
read what Vitamix has to say about it
I'm going to go straight to like the
stars and the reviews and everything and
that's really cool that like Commerce is
being so democratized and beauty is just
another you know category where it's all
about you know the woman electing brands
and electing her products and you know
searching for the best and I think into
the gloss is really just a reaction of
that and sort of an aggregator and like
a instigator of that behavior
yeah glossy is really well known now for
listening to customer feedback in your
product development cycle and
essentially now anyone on your team can
put a blog post up on into the gloss
saying we have this brand new product
idea what are your opinions what do you
all want how would you describe the most
ideal texture or fragrance or shade or
price point and how do you know whose
opinions to listen to I don't know how
do you listen to your gut what is that
like for you yeah so so it's interesting
I mean you know traditionally I'm not
sure how beauty brands arrived at what
products to make but for us there's
really only one logical conclusion which
is like talk to people whether that's
you know I mean I have my opinions about
products that I like but having
interviewed you know hundreds of the
most influential women from you know
politics to art to fashion to you know
girls on the street who have like cool
pink hair color and you want to know
where it where why I have certainly like
a lot of opinions but what's really
interesting more interesting is again
that like just just having a lot of
conversations and what's better than you
know posting something on Instagram and
within like 20 minutes having a thousand
responses about you know whether that
red lipstick that we're working on is
like skewing a little too blue or a
little too red and you know you've got
everyone from like a girl in her bedroom
in Ohio with 200 followers to like
makeup by Mario who's like Kim
Kardashian's makeup are shows like you
know 10 million followers writing like I
think it's a little blue so I mean
someone's paying him like a lot of money
to like give that to feedback which is
given to us for free on our Instagram so
I think it's nice that you know you can
kind of sift through that and it's
really an art and it's more of an art
than a science like we don't one-for-one
crowdsource we don't say like you know
tell us exactly what to make and we'll
shade matching we'll send it to you we
we really kind of combine our editorial
background as beauty editors with you
know hearing you know 30% of those
people saying it's too blue and then
you're like okay well I guess it's a
little too blue was there ever a time
when sort of the beauty hivemind was
incorrect and you followed an opinion
that in fact turned out to be wrong
I don't think I mean beauty's so
subjective we were just debating this
backstage you got into a big fight over
mascara because I was like nobody needs
a mascara to play calm no no I really
need one somebody you know you're not
talking about like you know underwear
it's like you can skip mascara so you
can't be writer you you can't be like
right or wrong so we haven't been like
led astray but we've definitely had to
make some tough calls like you know we
when we were making our priming
moisturizer rich we a bunch of you know
respondents said oh we really wanted in
a pump instead of a jar but when we
worked with our chemist and developed
this formula that included a lot of
their responses about ingredients we
realized we couldn't fit the product
into a pump it wouldn't come out so we
had to go the jar route and that was
that we explained to everyone this is
why it's not in a jar and you know and
now it's one of our best selling
products so I think it's just about that
transparency with the customer and like
you know really letting people know that
we're indexing on quality like always
above everything else and I think that
goes a long way yeah what happened to
the gloss and glossy I taught you about
women and beauty over the past seven
years so much I mean again I think you
know personally I love products I mean I
grew up really liking like Stila
and like you know a lot of beauty
products and trying a bunch of stuff but
beauty pre Instagram for YouTube really
YouTube you know it's like the number
one or two category after like tech
unboxing or unboxing of other things
which I did you know um but I think pre
pre that it was really this this very
solitary endeavor like if you in the
morning kind of like just you by
yourself like doing your thing and and
now it's such a connected like shared
activity or you know like knowledge
knowledge resource but the one thing
that I think overarching ly has been
interesting is the number of women who
like I start to send in some of you know
when I'm like when I used to do these
interviews in their bathrooms and I'd be
like hey can I come over and like you
know rifle through your medicine cabinet
and you know ask your about your beauty
routine and you'd have these really
powerful women from like you know
Arianna Huffington's
like Jenna Lyons being like
Oh me like no I'm really low maintenance
and I'd have to be like well like really
I mean okay like let's let's talk about
it was that mean for you you know can I
come over and then you go there you have
the cabinet's like flowing it's like
there's so many product and and so I was
like why is there this weird like beauty
shaming kind of like deeply ingrained
thing or you have to be like oh like you
know like no I don't really like me
beauty what and I think I think that's
really like funny and I think it's
because you know we're made to feel so
much like we don't know like we can't
have these opinions like there's some
you know brand or makeup artist or
someone somewhere who like knows way
more about you know you and also if you
like product then that means you're not
just waking up naturally just looking
beautiful you're actually using many
things and you know that's kind of like
frowned on by society so I think there's
a lot of cool like anthropological like
things around Beauty that are getting
unpacked now thanks to things like
coffee and lofts and YouTube
um and I'm curious about those inner
interviews that you conducted because as
you're saying you are asking really high
profile powerful women to let them
you're asking them to let you into their
house like into their bathroom with them
and essentially those interviews created
a really beautifully detailed snapshot
of that woman's relationship with
themselves and that as you as you
mentioned is usually a secret maybe only
a significant other a really close
family member might know what that woman
does to take care of herself and when
you were first starting out how other
than pestering them it sounds like did
you sort of get to the yes the I mean
asking is something I've always for
better for worse like it
I just always do it so I'm not very
self-conscious about like putting myself
out there and getting rejected and we
still get turned out I mean I'm
personally not doing the interviews
anymore but we get you know turned down
all the time I think I think you know
you know especially where it with where
technology is right now in social media
is every you know there's it's
double-edged sword this idea that
everyone can start something right and
and you're all here because I'm sure
your many many entrepreneurs and
and I think just like product of quality
is it really speaks for itself so I
think when you're you know trying to get
that that yes I mean for us a lot of it
was like look at this artery here's a
link to something we did with this
person like here's you know you could
will you will also look and sound
you know like hopefully it'll be
something you'll be proud of if you if
you do this and so I think quality
really baguettes quality and again in
this kind of like fast fashion age or
everyone can like put up an Instagram in
like 10 seconds and you know you can
really make a lot of content quickly I
think that kind of like premium
attention to detail content or product
is just goes a long way you've spoken a
bit about how Gracia is really
reinventing the traditional Beauty
experience can you describe that and
explain how you plan to transform it
yeah so we're mean we're really a pretty
young companies like two and a half
years old almost three years old in
October we are purely direct-to-consumer
so all sold through glossy calm and have
many hundreds of thousands of customers
now in in the in the United States and
soon internationally we're launching in
in October in the fall and actually my
business partner and I Henry's our
president and CEO oh he came from Index
Ventures in London and we've worked
together since since launching it was
funny so you're doing our board deck
yesterday or in town for board meeting
and he's always said and we've kind of
always said he has an idea just say
things over and over and then we would
wake up sometimes you saying you're like
wait that's not true he said he said us
being directed consumer is the value
proposition to the to the customer and
and I was like I know we always say that
the like she doesn't care that she's
getting it like directly from us that's
not like the value proposition like
maybe she even wants to just go get it
right you know that's the for like the
next day but what is you know really
interesting about how we're reinventing
the Beauty experiences that relationship
she feels with glossier because we have
such a direct one-to-one connection with
her so we have everyone's emails were
able to you know offer special like
access to things promotions to things
we're able to make replenishment easier
we're able to ask her specific questions
about what product she wants all of
which you know a brand that sold through
Sephora or sold at the drugstore is
unable to do because they don't know you
they don't you know they don't have any
of your data and they can't make that
experience really special for you so I
think you know that's kind of the
business case but the the impact case
which is you know why those ninety-five
seventy-seven percent of female
employees are all doing this is the
impact with glossier is that you know I
was I was doing all these Beauty
interviews and I was realizing that
there was this big disconnect between
like the affinity for the beauty brand
and the actual product so you might say
for example like I really love
Maybelline great lash but like do you
really have a relationship to Maybelline
like are you like you know do you like
ascribe to their set of values do you
like understand like you know where they
came from or like what they're up to
like in the background and so I thought
there was just this great opportunity
really to have this super connected
really modern brand in every sense of
the word so you know I guess we've
reinvented it in the sense of direct
consumer online but we also are you know
going into like our own retail and we
have a showroom in New York that's more
like an art gallery or like a clubhouse
and it is like a you know Sephora
there's actually barely any product in
it we have 22 products so you know it's
few and far between and it's become this
meeting place for women to actually like
meet up before brunch or like you know
help each other how to pick their shade
and there's like almost little need for
actual salespeople so I think the
opportunity to think about like what
what is beauty offline and kind of like
you know I think that's really
interesting to how it can bring women
together yeah sort of in listening to
you speak it sounds like you're starting
like your starting point was having
women create a relationship with
themselves then your shoes you're sort
of sharing that outward with other women
and there's sort of this big question is
like how do you scale that relationship
that relationship that you have with
your clients that they have with one
another and I've heard you name a couple
of things but just like how do you think
about that because it's again it's such
an in
submit thing that you're hoping to scale
to the masses yeah where we think about
all the time and like my head of comms
will kill me because I'm going to say
something really weird right now but
like I think I think about it a little
bit like like how are like religion
scaled right like you have like you have
like we always say about Gauthier like
it's it's the first beauty lifestyle
brand and the reason we say that is
because not only are we like addressing
like multiple categories kind of like
you know maybe it'll be a glossier
deodorant maybe they'll be like osceola
you know like I don't know tampon like I
our customers want kind of they trust us
and they really want like the glossier
version of X but the other thing is you
know you're interacting with engaging
with glossier throughout the day in ways
that you choose so it's like okay I want
to follow on Instagram okay I want like
X number of emails okay or you're just
like just shut up and give you a
moisturizer and I like don't want to
talk to you but and how you scale that
like I mean technology certainly helps
but I think like every woman can have
whatever relationship she wants like
with glossier you know and whether
that's like stickers on the back of her
phone to remind her like throughout the
days if she likes this like brand or you
know like whether she wants to come
every Saturday to like our showroom I
think it's up to her to like really
decide like what kind of how involved
she wants to be in in the brand and in
the building of the brand
and I think that's what's really
interesting too in terms of the
relationship it's like the relationship
to the customer in terms of creating
brands I think is going to be beyond
just glossy and beauty like something
that most of the great next generation
like you know CPG companies are going to
be built around this notion of like this
these relationships with customers and
this this real like two-way street um
late last year you raised a twenty four
million dollar series being late
Congrats on that how are you planning to
take over the world with that let's just
be in plan actually we're planning on
keeping it all in the bank you like it
literally I looked at our balloting
yesterday and it like was all there this
is good
we've been really conservative actually
so we've raised I guess I'd probably
like 40 something million but we were
actually like accident
only profitable a couple months left
last year which was like yeah see I
don't know we should clap or not that's
the other thing I'm like is that good
and my partner's like well depends of
Joy's like spend more marketing like
that so I went to art school by the way
so I did not I did not go to visit
school but to the point of our of
someone on stage before like that
curiosity is really important right that
kind of like naivete of being like huh
explain this to me that's served as well
but in terms of what we're doing with
with the money I think I mean we're
really lucky we've had 600 percent
growth in the last 12 months 600 percent
growth year before that and it's really
been a result of two things I would say
like incredible focus and discipline we
say no to way more things than we say
yes to that's really hard especially
because we could put ourselves in a
Sephora you know tomorrow and probably
like 4x revenue like but I don't know
that that would really help us achieve
the long-term impact we want in women's
lives and the other thing that's really
driven that has had nothing to do with
the money we've raised I mean 79 percent
of our growth last year was all based on
peer to peer recommendations so it's
it's not through paid it's not through
like an acquisition you know machine
it's just been through women telling
each other how much they love our
products and and and for that we're
really grateful so we're investing much
more in community efforts much more in a
little bit in a little bit in offline
but but really just on continuing to you
know make amazing product that people
want to talk about yeah and I know one
of the things that you said is that
you're opening some some retail and
that's super exciting and when you think
about the glossy retail experience in
your own mind what is your fantasy of
that like what do you want it to look
like in a dream Emily world I mean it
well that's us hearts that's a really
scary question because I want like birds
and like like like candy I I actually we
do we just had a kickoff meeting about
this
I referenced Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory and like the wallpaper that you
can lick so I'm not saying we should
have lickable wallpaper but I like the
excitement and the energy of like going
into something that's like this mecca
and this kind of like because who needs
stores anymore you know like why are you
opening like an offline like store if
you can just order it'll get there in an
hour or like the next day like truly
like that is the question we should all
be asking ourselves because we really
take a hard look and think about like
you know what you're doing and shopping
this weekend it should be cool like it
shouldn't just be about like procuring
there should be more birds yeah I mean I
don't know there's gonna be birds but I
think it should be more it's much more
experiential and so I think more about
hospitality that I do about like you
know sales per square foot
um yeah for sure uh when you think about
the beauty space what is it that sort of
makes you the most energized thinking
about the future what are you most
looking forward to I'm most looking
forward to the customer just like always
being right I think I think it's so cool
and she's always been right and that's
why that phrase exists but I think it's
the phrase it's never been truer than it
is today so it's actually not even from
like ceo/founder perspective but just
from like a consumer perspective like
how cool that there are so many options
but more importantly there's always
since so many options that's been the
problem like there's too many options
more importantly it's like there's just
so much great information there's so
many way to cut through those those
options there's like you know so many
ways to connect if you want to know how
to do a black cat eye you know you can
find like you know fifty thousand videos
like ten minutes on how to do that so I
love that the power the power dynamics
and beauty have just completely shifted
and I think they're going to shift more
and more and more and maybe it's like
some weird anarchist streak that like I
didn't know I have I just think it's
really cool that women are really like
the authors of their own lives when it
comes to you know beauty and many other
things
around the time that you first launched
glossier right you were sort of
launching into a hardware space like a
company that has now a physical product
which is traditionally very difficult
was there ever a time that you thought
you wouldn't make it but it was the
wrong thing well what am I doing here I
don't think so
and that's not to say that I was not
caught so you asked two questions like
is it raw is it the wrong thing never
always knew it was the right thing would
we not make it like sure I mean there's
a million things you know we like
scraped by for I mean into the boss is
totally bootstrapped I said like seven
hundred dollars so like my own money to
you know get it get it off the ground
and then we just relied on advertiser
dollars and you don't know when it was
basically like freelancing you don't
know when the next thing is going to
come through and of course when we first
launched glossier we pressed I'm not an
engineer but whenever the site went live
I don't know what we press but it was
fixed it was fixed in the morning and
like we didn't know who was going to
come or if anyone was going to order
anything like there we didn't start with
a wait list there were no pre sales like
it's just like it's on you know
does anyone does anybody want it so
there's definitely been like those
moments and so yeah it's been scary but
we just you just keep going like there's
no other option I don't know what I
would be doing so we're doing this yeah
that's a good that's a good point yeah
um what does it been like for you sort
of your evolution as a manager and the
CEO what's that been like um that's a
great question
presentation we were before was saying
so she was saying you're the best
sometimes you through the best creators
are not the best managers I'm not a good
manager but I'm a very good hire hire er
that word yeah
hire and it's because I love people and
I really believe in women and I really
believe in people and I love when women
especially like really surprised
themselves yeah and so so I might
changes every I would say like three
months as a CEO like I really go focus
on something else so for example the
next like three months I'm going to be
really focused on being our European
headquarters in London and I'll be you
know over there all the time
but as of now and probably for the last
12 months I've spent over 50% of my day
on HR people and hiring so that's
everything from interviewing every
single new employee from intern level to
CEO level to you know taking people out
for coffee I have probably two to three
I probably have three to four job
interviews a day and one to two coffees
a day with different members of our team
from you know Soviet level you know
graphic designers to our senior
engineers and in tech and and I think
that's just really important like I sit
with everybody like sometimes I say I'm
like the mom and mean girl who comes in
she's like you kids need anything
condoms like they're all like we're good
like we don't believe this alone but but
I think it's good to some of the best
there's no like hierarchy and ideas you
know so you can be an intern and have
some great observation about you know
workflow management and your idea really
needs to be listened to
so and the other thing I would say Glatt
we do really well at glossier and i
don't take credit for this this is
really like ingrained in our culture is
we take big bets on people so like our
SVP of marketing ali weiss no relation
although i always wish they work it
she's really smart she graduated HBS
like
two years ago and had never worked in
marketing but given the nature of
marketing today and how quickly it's
evolving and you know the PlayBook with
people with playbooks it's not so much
about a playbook right you have to say
like what matters right now
like what matters today and what matters
for your product in your company in
which social channel matters in which
social channel don't matter and Ali
never done marketing but now she's you
know our SVP of marketing and she's
she's she's crushing it so we take
really big bets on people and I think
given especially in fields like
marketing you know it's changing so much
that experience is you know
sometimes not even the most important
indicator of success thank you so much
for sharing that all with us today thank
you thanks everybody
[Music]
you